JONAH JONES: Imagine you're
sitting in a cafe with a friend
and they draw you, on
the back of a napkin,
how to get to their house.
They're not going to draw
you every single road
and every single business
that's on the way.
They're going to
simplify this for you.
We wanted to emphasize
those things on Google Maps.
It's almost like having a
cartographer in your pocket
now.
Because we can, now, rebuild
the perfect map for every place
and for every person.
We've never been able
to do this before.
SIAN TOWNSEND: I'm interested
if someone likes Google Maps.
But what matters
so much more is,
can they actually
use Google Maps?
JONAH JONES: The research can
provide these deep insights
into how real people
are using the products.
Put this in front of real
people and watch them use it.
And see if they're struggling,
or if things are working well.
SIAN TOWNSEND: One thing
we noticed in research
was that, some people
had problems navigating
street view, which was kind
of disappointing to us,
because that's really
where all the fun is,
being able to explore.
So what we did is we prototyped
some alternative ways of giving
people a stronger
visual cue, introducing
a little arrow and a circle,
just to indicate, Click Here.
Suddenly we saw in
studies that people
were able to get the
most out of the product.
JONAH JONES: You're
seeing a trend, generally,
in modern design.
Technology should be
getting out the way.
And we're trying to make
all of the interactions
happen on the map, itself.
We call that making the map the
user interface, because we're
taking all of the controls
away from the edge of the map,
and placing all the interactions
directly on the map.
The thing that wows most
people about the design
of the new Google Maps is, we've
got Google Earth built directly
into the browser now,
which is pretty cool.
We have all of this
incredible imagery,
all the way from Satellite
View, down via Street View,
and all the way
even under water.
The Great Barrier Reef
is a great example
of that, because it allows
you to explore something
that, maybe, you're never going
to get to explore in reality.
We draw inspiration from
a variety of sources
all the time.
And I think nature's
a really nice one.
We had this problem,
which is that we
have this incredible
satellite imagery,
and then we were overlaying the
roads and the labels on top.
But it really felt like we
were obscuring the imagery
with the roads.
One day, I was
sitting in a park,
and I saw a leaf
lying next to me.
And we realized that the roads
and everything are really
quite similar to
the veins on a leaf.
You can see the major highways
here, and the arterioles,
and the little, local
roads around here.
And what makes this really work
is the fact that it's brighter
and there's this, kind
of, darker contrast
around the edges.
So we took that design approach
and put that back into Maps.
Tiny, little, subtle
changes are giving
it slightly brighter coloring
and slightly darker casing.
Now the satellite maps look
slightly more nature-inspired.
And they look more
holistic and more
like they fit together,
instead of two overlays.
SIAN TOWNSEND: Collaboration
between the designers
and researchers
at Google is more
of an ongoing conversation.
Seemingly small
tweaks to a product
can have a massive impact.
It's through these
kinds of conversations
that we start to pinpoint
ways that we can reduce stress
in people's lives, and make
technology that people love.